يستضيف مقر الاتحاد الاوروبي في بروكسل
مؤتمرا دوريا لجمع الاموال من اجل سوريا
التي ضربها زلزال عنيف هذا العام مما فاقم
المحنه القاسيه التي تعاني منها منذ
اندلاع صراع في 2011
ووصف الثلاثه منظمات في الامم المتحده
لاحتياجات في سوريا بانها ضخمه وقالت ان
عشره تمويل المطلوب فقط هو الذي تم تامينه
حتى الان لمشروعات عام
لمساعده السوريين في الداخل واللاجئين
منهم في المنطقه
معنى من بروكسل الجزيره ايضا هناك حديث عن
ان عشر ما هو مطلوب فقط تم تامينه حتى
الان
دعم بالفعل تستمر اعمال هذا المؤتمر
ويتوقع ان يتم الاعلان في الساعات المقبله
عن اهم القرارات وعن حجم التبرعات التي
تتعهد الدول المانحه بتقديمها للاجئين
وللدول المستضيفه لكن قبل ذلك عقد منسق
السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ندوه صحفيه كرر خلالها ربما ما جاء في
كلمته الافتتاحيه ردد لاءات الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان صح التعبير لا تطبيع مع
النظام السوري لا حل سوى الحل السياسي في
سوريا وقال ايضا ان دول الاتحاد ستواصل
فرض العقوبات على النظام السوري وقال ان
هذه العقوبات لا تستهدف الشعب السوري وان
الاوضاع المزريه في هذا البلد تعود الى
فساد النظام على حد تعبيره لكنه تطرق ايضا
الى حجم المساعدات التي سيقدمها الاتحاد
الاوروبي تحدث عن مليار ونصف المليار يورو
خلال هذا السنه ازيد من هذه السنه ازيد من
350 مليون يورو في السنه المقبله وقال ان
هذه المساعدات كافيه لتامين حاجيات
اللاجئين وايضا الدول المستضيفه طبعا هذا
الكلام يلقى ردا في اوساط بعض الدول
المستضيفه بعض وزراء الخارجيه الذين
يشاركون في هذا المؤتمر دقوا ناقوس الخطر
قالوا ان هذه او بعض هذه المساعدات لا تصل
وان دول هم تعيش اوضاع اقتصاديه مزريه
وانها ملف اللاجئين يؤثر على الاوضاع
الداخليه على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه على
المنظومه التعليميه كما جاء في كلمه وزير
خارجيه الاردن بعد الدول الاخرى كلبنان
بدورها رسمت واقعا قاتما وزير الخارجيه
قال انه يخشى ان يحدث عنف في لبنان نظرا
للاوضاع الاقتصاديه السيئه وبالتالي كل
هؤلاء يطالبون برفع الدعم ولكن اكدوا ايضا
في هذا الاجتماع على ضروره بحث اليات ربما
للعوده الطوعيه للاجئين هذا ابرز ما جاء
الى حدود الساعه في اعمال هذا المؤتمر تمت
رهان كبير خاصه في اوساط منظمات
الدعم الانساني والتعاون التي تصبو بدورها
الى رفع المساعدات لتامين حاجيات اللاجئين
خاصه الاطفال الذين يعانون هذه الازمه نعم
ايمن الزبير